what do you think about the body
positivity movement what about it so I
saw a bill burbot from his show at Red
Rocks and he had this really fascinating
Insight so I've learned about this thing
called intra sexual competition right
what intra-sexual competition okay so
women competing with women for men and
men competing with men for women yeah
the current world both popular media and
also the men's online dating space yeah
is saying that
men and women are each other's
adversaries right the
losses your gain and vice versa but it
seems like most competition happens
interest sexually not intersexually burn
nailed it in this piece what he was
saying was how have we got ourselves to
the stage where normal average can't
remember your name-looking women have
convinced all of their bigger friends
that they don't need to lose weight
the reason for that is that it makes you
the hot one in your group of friends
you reduce your own intersexual
competition by encouraging body
positivity it's like you can keep on
eating you fat lose a toe like so that
and I it made me see body positivity
through an entirely new lens there's no
woman that's proud to be fat that is a
myth
this is not true the even the skinniest
women don't think they're skinny enough
like if you actually believe that these
fat girls on the internet that are
saying how proud they are of their body
are actually proud you just don't know
any women at all women are constantly
scrutinized and for their weight it
doesn't matter how like even those fit
girl like the most fit athletic girl is
upset she's not skinny like a model and
that skinny girl that's a model is upset
she's not fit like the athletic girl
everybody is they're constantly worried
about their bodies like this idea that
there's these like fat confident chicks
no maybe if you've been fat your whole
life you've learned how to accept it and
you have another confidence that like
these skinny girls don't have because
they're trying to live up to these
unrealistic expectations but I truly do
not believe every fat girl you see
walking down the street is like proud to
be fat while they're fee-fi-fo-fum and
all over a mall right like there's
they're Inc they're embarrassed about
that and they want to do something to
fix it right you don't want to come on
bro
okay listen do you want to do that you
walk into the Apple Store the iPads are
[ __ ] shaking and [ __ ] like that
that's not a that's a problem right that
is a problem you're trying to get a
brand new iPad the guy is telling you
about it it's popping out the charger
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
here oh my God is there a beanstalk in
this right I think there's a beanstalk
in this Apple Store is that do you take
the Beanstalk to The Genius Bar like how
do I do you know I don't think there's
any girl that's actually confident about
that and I think they're trying to mask
that confidence we were talking about
earlier tell me about that that
interesting point now that thing I
forgot about what is that well I think
that there's there's a couple of things
going on here like you can and should be
happy with where you're at but also want
more I think the problem comes when you
try and tell other people that this is
the way that they should be right so
that's the inner Citadel the inner
Citadel is I damage my leg I try to fix
it if I can't then I chop it off and I
announce that the desire for legs is
misguided and must be subdued by
everybody so how many people that are a
part of the body positivity movement are
there because they struggle to lose
weight and then announced that the
entire world's view of weight and
Health's link is completely misguided
and that's wrong like you can be uh you
know we're saying here embrace the
person that you are as the the shorter
guy that maybe doesn't have as much
money and maybe doesn't have the right
job but like what can you do right so
the same thing goes for this you can be
perfectly happy in the position that you
are without telling everybody else that
they need to adhere to your biases yeah
you have to accept things you can't
change I think the thing with weight is
we perceive it as something that can be
changed quite easily especially if you
have good metabolism like if you're
skinny without doing nothing you're like
oh you must be fat because you're
overeating and lazy but the reality is
is there are different metabolisms right
like some people just are fatter it's
harder for them to lose weight they
gotta try way harder and they gotta
sacrifice way more now my question is
like how much you want to sacrifice we
were talking about this earlier like I
would rather be fat than David Goggins
any day of the week that seems like the
worst life ever like the guy got no
[ __ ] toenails like he's saying his
knees are completely uh devoid of any
cartilage like it's a con like he got a
whole team just to get up and run every
single [ __ ] day and it's like that
sounds awful like I'd rather be plump
and enjoying meals with my friends and
like just embracing dessert I love
dessert I wonder why they're awesome I
wonder whether it's an issue with theory
of mind I wonder whether it's because
you can't imagine what it would be like
let's say I don't think that this is
necessarily the case but let's say that
Goggins takes as much pleasure from
running 30 miles a day yep and doing 500
push-ups because you do from going out
with your friends let's just say that
that's the case let's say that there is
a person for whom they can be as happy
and confident at the size that they are
as the person that is in whatever the
shape is that's not to say that there
isn't on average I don't think that
that's the case for most people I think
that most people end up being happy with
the varied life that gives them a good
bit of freedom and has a little bit of
discipline yeah I agree with you
completely and again that was just me
personally based on what I value right
so uh the the one tricky thing with with
body positivity is the assumption that
these things are healthy and I think
nobody's saying don't love your body
what they're saying is don't mislead
people into thinking that that's health
right like it is not healthy like
doctors say that this is not healthy and
I think that's the only pushback if
you're like yo I'm fat and I'm unhealthy
but I like to live like this I don't
think anybody's gonna be angry at you
why do I give a [ __ ] that you're fat but
what if they say I'm fat and I'm
confident like this great your life do
what the [ __ ] you want you're not
hurting me
I'm fat and this is healthy now you're
misleading people now there's other
people like okay I could potentially be
fat and you know I don't have to worry
about my body at all and you can I guess
do that but it is misleading it's not
it's not true in other news I've got to
tell you about athletic greens you are
not eating enough fruit and vegetables
in your diet and you know it and this is
going to help Dr Andrew human and Tim
Ferriss have been hopping on about it
for years and I always wondered why it
is the best green strength that I've
found and I've tried pretty much
everyone it tastes great and it gives
you nutritional insurance through 75
vitamins minerals and Whole Foods
sourced ingredients in one scoop that
you take every single day if you're
starting the new year looking to give
yourself some good nutritional
improvements this is a great place to
begin and there is a 60-day money-back
guarantee so you can buy it and try it
for 59 days and if you do not like it
they will give you your money back also
you get a Year's free Supply vitamin D
five free travel packs free pots shakers
and that 60 day money back guarantee
head to athletic greens.com wisdom
that's athleticgreens.com
wisdom what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]